Statesmen.
That is the American wing, would you say,
the American version of the Kingsmen?
And you guys are all named after beverages.
What is your name?
Tequila.
[Conan] You're Tequila.
Yep. Tequila.
And you get to use a rifle,
which I think would be incredibly fun
'cause you could do all kinds of fun tricks,
When I was a kid, I had a toy rifle,
and I would just spend hours alone without a girl
playing with the toy rifle
(audience laughs)
which made me the babe magnet I am today.
It must be fun to play with that?
No, it was. I mean, it's an epic,
like Americana, The Rifleman, it's one of the best
[Conan] Chuck Connors, The Rifleman.
Yeah, exactly. So I got to do the Chuck Connors.
[Conan] That's so cool.
It's amazing, yeah.
Jeff Bridges, your name is, what is your name?
(audience cheers)
I'm Champagne.
[Conan] What's that?
Champagne!
[Conan] You're Champagne.
But I don't dig my name.
I don't dig my name so I make people call me Champ.
Champ, that's nice.
They assigned you Champagne, you didn't like it so you
Champagne's a little too light weight.
Do you like champagne in real life?
I don't.
[Conan] You don't.
Terrible hangover. You ever get hung over on champagne?
Yes, we've all had a champagne hangover. It's not good.
It's amazing.
You can't go anywhere without people screaming "Dude."
It's just your life.
Yeah. I'm proud.
(audience shouts "Dude")
And do you see he's wearing jellies?
Are you wearing jellies?
(audience cheers)
You're nothing if not comfortable.